this Fresco found on the wall of a house
in the ancient Roman city of Pompeii
looks remarkably like a pizza
historians can't quite agree on just how
far back the origins of pizza go but
it's believed to have started in Naples
Pompeii was buried in Ash from a
volcanic eruption in 79 A.D making this
depiction nearly 2 000 years old
this one is peculiar because what we see
is a kind of sacrificial flatbread an
offering with perhaps seasoning on it
some spices some kind of condiment
it's an image that obviously to the
modern Observer immediately brings to
mind a pizza since we are near Naples
obviously it's not a pizza but perhaps
it's a distant ancestor of the food
distant ancestor or not a lot has
changed in the time since but people's
appetites maybe not as much as we think
we are in an atrium of a house that was
already partially excavated over a
hundred years ago during our work we
found this Fresco a very common type of
Xenia a welcoming gift depicting things
like fruit a flatbread and a goblet of
wine that was found in Pompeii slice it
up fold it over grill or crisp it in a
Wood-Fired oven however you eat it
there's no denying Pizza as a global
favorite enjoyed by all
this find could ignite a heated debate
among historians and archaeologists is
this pizza's long-lost relative or is it
something else entirely a question worth
taking a bite of Mike level Al Jazeera